[Music]
imagine a river hot enough to kill you
said to be the home of a powerful
Amazonian water spirit that place is
real and I've been there
it's the shine I think Mishka the
boiling River of the Amazon
[Music]
my name is Anthony Russell and I am a
geothermal scientist and conservationist
as a boy in Lima my grandfather told me
this crazy story about the search for
the lost city of gold
there was a detail on a story about a
river that boiled I certainly imagined
it but never never really dwelled on it
it was just a veto it's getting much
hotter
turns out this place is real so the
boiling River is located in the heart of
the central Peruvian Amazon the hottest
temperature I've measured was over 210
degrees Fahrenheit to put that into
everyday terms the average coffee is
roughly 130 degrees it's hard to
physically imagine that much hot water
you stick your hand in and you will see
second third-degree burns a matter of
seconds I've seen a number of animals
fall into the boil remember everything
from birds to reptiles complex organisms
like us we don't do well at those high
temperatures we literally start to cook
on the bone feeling that heat come into
you breathing in this thick hot air
where you can feel the air heating you
up inside your nose you can feel it
going into your lungs you can feel the
presence of your lungs because of the
heat of the air it still gives me
goosebumps
the true name of the boiling river is
shun I think beach town and that means
according to one of the local shamans
boiled with the heat of the Sun it's
spectacular it's this place is totally
redefined what it means to be sacred for
me I think once you've experienced
something that's truly moved you you
love it and you can't let that go every
year about 8 million tonnes of waste
lavas are dumped into the Indian rivers
all the pesticides and insecticides that
were used to grow these flowers mixes
with the river water making it highly
toxic we decided to do something about
it
[Music]
Indians depends on the river water for
drinking water for our agriculture and
for our basic needs in Hinduism we
Hindus go to temples and offer flowers
to our gods once these flowers have been
offered to our gods they become sacred
they cannot be dumped in the hospital so
according to religious customs they are
dumped into the river Ganges
once these flowers have been dumped in
the river it creates havoc in the
fragile ecosystem of the water body we
had decided that we want to solve the
flower problem but we didn't have a
solution so we started going to temples
biding for the race class but turned out
no one would trust us boys coming and
asking you for waste you're not sure
what they'll do with it so slowly and
slowly he started with around twelve
kilos of these flowers and in a month we
started collecting 80 kilograms of these
flowers
today our trucks go to the temple
directly like these lace flowers in bins
and bring them to a facility we have a
capacity of about eight point seven tons
of estas burning these flowers are
treated to remove all the pesticides and
insecticides and convert them into
products we make charcoal free incense
takes bathing bars and now we are
launching biodegradable alternative
styrofoam made from these ways flowers
river Ganges is the holiest River in the
world it says a dip in the river Ganges
can remove all yourselves when I see
river Ganges in the state that it is in
I feel sad and I feel that the status
quo needs to be changed
[Music]
[Applause]
Montana is a landlocked state it blows
my mind every day but there is waves in
the river and you can surf them on
surfboards just like you would in the
ocean we'd have a huge surf culture here
in Missoula my name is Kevin Ben Hart
Brown I go by KB and I own strong water
Mountain surf company we are the
original Mountain surf shop and still
the only surf shop in the state of
Montana
I mean it's cowboy country here surfing
is in my soul my very first earliest
memories at the age of three is visiting
my grandparents in San Diego and seen
surfing in the ocean and for whatever
reason I've been kind of searching for
surfing my whole life and I happened to
be here in Missoula Montana and tapped
into river surfing in the river it's a
standing wave so the wave is essentially
stationary you're going back and forth
across the wave but the wave is kind of
in one place the water's coming at you
it's pretty amazing
you know we've built a really strong
River surf community here there's just a
ton of support and good vibes and good
energy this whole connection with nature
correlates directly with kind of that
same vibe that you get in the ocean not
a lot of people know about River surfing
but there's River surfing communities
popping up everywhere and it's just
starting to explode for me personally
it's about doing what people don't think
you can do and proving that you can do
it and you know just getting out and
having a good time sharing the sport
it's exciting and fun to be on this
whole new frontier floating markets have
been at the center of communities in
Thailand for hundreds of years they were
originally built along canals and rivers
at a time when water transport played an
important role in daily life one of the
most popular in Thailand is the ambough
a floating market 45 miles from Bangkok
it stretches 30 miles along it now on
the Mekong River
and today hundreds of vendors use the
empower floating market to sell and cook
a wide variety of delicious Thai dishes
[Music]
Muhammad a fillet to a massive sword la
cama cama so for now our cinema on Io
meconium and Anya Khan how many young
Kokua - Akua Aloha and welcome in
Italian mouth company in Mattoon I'm a
bad woman we're gonna go over there but
we're gonna go on living gone but you
only know me I'm good I am good I forget
a gimmick like Indiana Bobby girl Roy
that's all the news tom jung jae-young
all right Morty
[Music]
typical America to me King me home then
he threw me my name Eva pal - uh-huh
pick up oh man ha ha ha ha place
damn Tampa - atif on low for New York
and home hang tight for my job from
Target or a balloon animals a battalion
[Music]
hey como la la melancholy song not happy
I'm Hawaiian er7 we love how her gnomes
so keep in focus or and I'm kind of how
that that doll I'm at like I got and I
am well my loot up garage hidden money
should I look at money lawmen Canada you
allow you got some comment I used up a
VPN on today's journey takes us to the
Dutch town of key turn key torn is just
like any normal town with one exception
roads they don't have them the immense
of the sine alpha is open boat somewhat
of an anomaly the feature of the
platform the stemming coma and all this
much local severe egg meant by didn't a
local Burgermeister from Quito now I
design fear and 200m onus off of here
and I love homeless hydrogens and boats
lots of boats now who adduction off his
own for faithfulness s all the board to
develop either he door that's young one
of the town's residents he's known for
punters a flat-bottomed boat that
originated in Quito
a fellow Stanek he daughter Mara Montiel
hatch act off there over the elevator
and where there are boats there are
bridges
167 to be exact and just like any town
people leave their groceries their
furniture their beer you name it
but in guitar they must pass through an
time he's the town's bridge guard it
also girls masters to may stop up unless
that little daughter still
when they look at the often three on the
boat while we're just opening for one of
those boats is the fire boat this is
Bart and Erik I need to hold that Black
Dahlia there's a middle row need can
call those dude hidden dorky told ya
feel plug fill warning and absorb
loosing from don't have the right
Murdock for the rather from the e-field
wrinkling and boat and the sinking
design of and this is young he's in
charge of maintaining the natural lands
around II thought I was alone kid or
than the mr. velman and sank owner
better a boat brag bad and yeah the
queen of the boat that's even a don't
need to fill me but a sober to say she
don't know how ferocious that animal so
there you have it the residence of Keith
or improved their life without asphalt
traffic and trips to the DMV can be
pretty damn great roads who needs him
baggy torn
you